hello welcome to everyone to our next
session in the pythera global edition
2022 no 2031 but it's still the time is
is going fast uh my name is jana i'll be
your host for this session i'm super
happy to be here now i will introduce
our
speaker
john jan is the ceo and principal data
scientist at coefficient his experience
in data science and software engineering
spans multiple industries and
applications and his passion for the
power of data extends far beyond his
work for
coefficient clients
in april 17 he created excess 50 in
order to predict the uk general election
using open data and advanced modelling
techniques
previous experience includes leader
scientists at yplan
business analytics at apple genomics
research and imperial college london
building an end tech startup in nodium
developing a strategy and technological
infrastructure for international
nonprofit startup sdir education and
losing his lead to many hackathons along
the way
john is also an organizer of pi data
bristol co-found a humble data in 19 to
promote diversity in data science
through a program of free bootcamps and
in 2020 was a committee shared for the
pi data global conference so we have a
former member here
he is currently a fellow of newspeak
house with interest in open data
aei ethics and promote diversity in tech
today he is going to speak about agile
data science how to implement agile
workflows for analytics and machine
learning
so you're welcome and the connection is
yours
thank you ever so much diana
uh so my objective for this talk is to
make this the most valuable talk you
watch at partisan global 2021 as
measured by your team's productivity in
2022
so what's the big deal about agile i'm
sure you've heard of it it's a big thing
71 of organizations are using it and
this is 2018. uh 90 percent of companies
who did try it said that they benefited
from adopting agile six percent of those
companies saw revenue and profit growth
after using it and agile projects as
measured by pwc are 28 more successful
than traditional projects these slides
will be made available i'll tweet them
out after this talk and uh these are all
linked and sourced so you can dig into
these stats
so here's the outline of talking to talk
about motivations what is agile how do
we actually go through it it's more of a
what do i wish i'd known a year ago when
i was just starting to apply it to our
data science teams
so motivations this is one of my least
favorite questions as a consultant when
a client says how long is this thing
going to take and i'm like oh i don't
know and they say come on ballpark
because this is a recipe for unhappy
bunnies the date comes along we're not
ready the client's upset cause they've
made promises my team is upset because
they've worked overtime
the way we're working just isn't working
uh and so there are all sorts of ways of
doing this can't we just get better at
estimating people are bad at estimating
for example the sydney opera house
estimated to take four years seven
million dollars it took 14 years 100
million dollars even when you can throw
all the best consultants at projects we
just
have a habit of going over time over
budget so maybe there's another way so
here's my journey to agile six years as
uh principal aid sciences coefficient
and only in the last year about a year
ago i read a book i read this i really
recommend if this is one thing you take
away go get this book it's fun uh it's a
it's a novel about it and devops and
it's a bit too close to the bone if you
work in corporates i.t
so in 2021 i find myself managing three
data science teams up to three workshops
a day through coefficient uh multiple
side projects and also running the
company and the one-to-ones and
all the finance and legal stuff that
comes with running a company and i think
the thing that made this work for us was
really going deep into agile
so i'm just going to say this now
there's a load of the stuff that we have
learned way more than i can fit into 30
minute talk is behind this link this is
the first time for this talk only that
we've opened up basically our own
internal playbook as to how we do agile
so check it out
so
first of all what is this thing
let's go through some terminology
there's a lot of buzzwords are they
needed i don't know but we need to know
the buzzwords for me to teach you this
so agile it's just a system to manage
your work using time limited iterations
those iterations called sprints one two
four week cycles and you're delivering
working increments what does that mean
it's output that can be tested or
reviewed so if you're building an etl
pipeline then by the end of that sprint
someone can actually review a partially
working etl pipeline or if it's an
analysis there's some analysis some can
review and feedback on the whole idea is
to get feedback from your stakeholders
from your managers whoever it's going to
sooner because they might just flag
something that puts a real spanner in
the work sounds it's good to know these
things sooner rather than later then we
talk about stories a story is a single
unit of work usually completed within a
sprint for me this is 20 minutes a few
days of work so that's what we call a
story and then an epic is a collection
of stories related together this is
actually a really nice way of organizing
your work i don't see a lot of data
science teams necessarily organizing the
work into stories and epics i think it's
great because if we've got the epic of
improve the marketing team's data
capacity uh in q3 2021 as an epic and we
can see all the related epics going
about the last couple of years i am
laying the breadcrumbs for future data
science teams to understand what's been
done before and so it's all about
reproducible data science you can
actually do this and help your future
teams find out what's been done before
and they might just find that you've
done something before you learned a load
of things that were non-intuitive the
time and they can save themselves days
or weeks of time of not doing that thing
or just updating your code and making it
a little bit more modern but just
re-running it it's much faster
so i'm going to go through some myths in
today's uh talk federal
is a methodology it's not it's a bunch
of values and it's a bunch of principles
it's not a methodology there are however
lots of different methodologies that
adhere to the agile philosophy uh most
of them uh most people think this is
just scrum but there are other
methodologies available scrum kanban
lean extreme programming you may have
heard some of these things most people
if i ask them they're like yeah we're
agile-ish so i'm not going to going deep
into too many of these i'm basically
just giving you here is a methodology
you can copy it's what we've implemented
in multiple
client data teams this year we found it
to work we've really iterated it so this
is our approach to agile agile ish so a
little bit more terminology what is lean
it's the toyota production system if you
read lean startup that's the toyota
production system applied to companies
it's about iterations quick iterations
learning cycles and evolving your
workflows as well
kanban visualize your stories on a board
um
through a workflow one nice feature is
limiting the amount of stories limiting
the work in progress you have factories
are really good at doing this they know
that if you've got lots of stuff piling
up then you end up just doing loads of
work managing all the work and kanban
helps to prevent that so you actually by
focusing on doing less you do more you
do use faster then the scrum which is a
very step-by-step system we're going to
be deep diving into scrum a little bit
today uh scrum talks about the backlog
this is just all the things you might
want to do but not necessarily have
authorized to do quite yet then there's
your stand up lots of people do
stand-ups especially in remote working
teams short daily team meetings check
progress although most teams i think do
stand-ups wrong they talk about like
what did the people do today yesterday i
think you should be reviewing your
kanban board where are all the stories
and the items that we're working on and
then the relevant people can speak as to
their progress and the blockers and
what's going on there so there's there's
one little tip
so we're talking about scrum what is
gram it's just a life cycle step by step
by step so uh you have your product
backlog basically your epics your epic
could be deploy my machine learning
model within that epic it's broken down
into a bunch of stories these form your
sprint backlog and so let's say we're
going to select the following stories
we're going to create an api version our
data with dvc and deploy to aws lambda
that's what my team is going to try and
achieve in the next two week sprint so
that's our sprint black clock once
selected we go into the sprint process
and that's just um you know very uh
daily quick check-ins but otherwise
letting the team self-organize self stay
on top of their own communications and
broadly focus on getting the job done at
the end of that sprint we then got a
working increment of software
so let me give you the meetings and our
agendas please feel free if you've never
tried agile steal these slides and just
literally apply our technique and start
from there so i'm gonna start with myth
number three lots of people think agile
is very undisciplined because lots of
executives in business say yeah we do
agile what they mean is what they're
nimble or they didn't really have a
strategy and they're just pretending
agile is not having strategy this is
nonsense okay so don't fall for it uh
call people out on that
help educate your leaders and if you're
a leader watching this um
i hope you enjoy this i hope this is
educational for you come and talk to me
i'm very happy to chat further so here
is our agenda for
the most important meeting i think i
don't know maybe retros and more so but
sprint planning to start a sprint maybe
30 minutes
you can adjust this as you go
and so find out what's your resource
availability let's say we've got two
team members alice is available for full
10 days of a two-week sprint uh bob only
two days he's uh on holiday uh then
what's your goal our goal for sprint
broadly is we want to deploy our machine
learning model so then we write up our
stories we figure out what are the
stories that we need so we can achieve
that goal and then we select the stories
to move into the sprint then we go
through an uh estimation process i'm
going to go into this shortly where we
estimate how much effort it's going to
be how much value it's going to be
through that we identify if there's
anything that's
huge amounts of effort and high risk
also if there's things that are higher
for low reward let's maybe think about
whether they should be in the sprint
right now and de-scope those items as
appropriate
meeting number two this is the sprint
look ahead this is so we work in two
week sprints and so every other week
we've got our mid sprint look ahead and
this is getting into a really nice
productivity tip uh dwight eisenhower
said especially whenever our affair
seems to be in crisis we're almost
compelled to first give attention to the
urgent present rather than the important
future so if you've seen the eisenhower
matrix the sprint look ahead is
basically a hack to protect us from
ourselves and focus on the non-urgent
important things it's so much easier to
decide what's important when it's a week
away
in a look ahead versus it's the sprint
starts tomorrow and everything's urgent
right now let's just focus on the urgent
stuff so it's a really nice hack uh i
really recommend trying these out so
you're focusing on just what's happening
in the next sprint not this one we'll
review this one well literally every day
through a 15 minute uh stand up
and then what are the tickets we might
want to add in to capture our higher
level priorities so it's taking a step
back for 10 000 foot view
then we have uh the end of sprint
meeting this is a sprint review or if
you've got clients or big stakeholders
you can have a sprint showcase which is
really fun you just get to say right
this is our new uh iterable uh working
you know product stage and we review
what's been delivered what's been done
what's not been done is there anything
that we didn't estimate very well
so what do we know it's a forced meeting
that forces you to learn things and
think about how do we improve our
process
but you celebrate the wins it's a very
celebratory meeting also just thinking
of all the things that are not yet done
do we even have a definition of done
how do we know when to stop in the world
of machine learning or analytics or r d
you can really go deep into a rabbit
hole sometimes so having a clear
definition of done and sometimes that's
literally we're going to spend one
sprint just optimizing this model we're
going to try everything we can to
optimize this model then we're going to
check in see what the model accuracy and
the model performance is and decide if
we want to uh reinvest another sprint in
further optimization and that at some
point is a conversation with your
stakeholders it's a business decision uh
model uh recall and precision have gone
up by five percent in the last two weeks
of effort is that worth it for another
five percent from another two weeks it
depends how much that five percent is
worth to the company so it's a really
nice uh flow that i think fits nicely
into into data science teams
then we have the retrospective i
actually think maybe this is the most
important meeting uh it's also the one
that is most likely to be skipped
so it's your opportunity to get to with
your team and just reflect uh what's
going well what could have gone better
what do we change about our process the
reason i think it's the most important
meeting is because
it doesn't really matter how you start
agile or what form or flavor you choose
as long as you have a retrospective
you're going to have the opportunity to
evolve your process uh to go from four
week sprints to two weeks sprints or
getting rid of your kanban or uh getting
rid of all of scram as long as you have
this you can evolve your process
that's that's the killer part of this
for me uh so the other thing is
be very kind to each other i really
think there's a nice thing called the
prime directed by norm kerf regardless
of what we discover we understand and
truly believe that everyone did the best
job they could given what they knew at
the time their skills abilities
resources available and the situation at
hand this uh i've learned from there's a
fantastic agile company called made tech
in the uk and i really recommend their
book they've got a whole book on agile
team
so
how to run a retro there's lots more in
that book i'll show that at the end in
my resources
so we've got our four meetings and if
you just start doing those meetings
you're on the way to agile in a big way
like that's almost the whole thing
uh
but one of those was involving adding
estimates into effort and value so how
do we go about doing that okay so myth
number four agile can't meet deadlines
i think that's nonsense okay so agile
projects have been proven to be less
likely to fail proven to have a greater
speed to market why is that well if
you're aiming to do less in each sprint
you actually deliver stuff you get
feedback sooner higher communication
uh which all and all of this is is
proven to be faster turnarounds you get
to your end goal sooner so greater speed
to market you also have higher quality
code your teams are also more motivated
and productive on average this is not a
promise it's just research and
statistics uh have have found this is on
average what agile projects deliver
however i think when it comes to
deadlines you have fixed print cycles
your team gets really good as you get
into your fourth fifth sixth sprint uh
into understanding roughly what can be
done in a two-week sprint they get much
better at estimating i can promise you
that between your first print and your
fistprint they're gonna be way better at
estimating uh what a large task is
versus a small task
about actively thinking through what are
the things that might go wrong here
what's the worst case scenario do i
really know how to deploy something to
aws lambda or am i just being really
over optimistic there
and then you have the review process and
the retro which forces getting even
better at the estimation and
understanding what is capable of
delivering
and you're measuring all of that along
the way so your teams become better at
forecasting how long things will take
the more you do agile which means i
think it's much more likely to deliver
to schedules because you're gonna have
more accurate conversations right up
front about what's possible
and if things do come up you've got a
really really uh fantastic communication
workflow uh that all of your
stakeholders and your team can
understand exactly where things are
through your kanban boards for example
so that's a little mess
so
how do we do estimation in the face of
uncertainty software is hard enough data
science is
even harder like machine learning
estimation
kind of tricky so the trick here is
people are great at relative estimates
so let's say uh here's a couple epic so
we're going to work on this sprint we've
got some stories around deployment and
let's try this really cool new looking
uh light gbm style model that's now in
cycle learn uh so what we do
is we first of all estimate our effort
points these are also called story
points i think effort points are
slightly more descriptive so what is an
effort point it's not time it's effort
because
someone who's been
i don't know coding for five ten years
is maybe faster at building a faster
api app than someone who's just started
out so it's not time it's effort and you
all agree on relative effort most the
time someone who's built a fast api app
several times i'm pretty sure sebastian
ramirez is going to build a fast api app
faster than i will and so again effort
is not equal to time but it is relative
to each other so
all we say is i recommend t-shirt sizing
small medium large if you have to go
higher but try and keep it relatively um
constrained now you'll notice the
numbering system is a fibonacci sequence
so one two three five eight thirteen why
is that because as we go from large to
extra large we get really it's really
hard to di uh differentiate between is
that four point five point six points
it's reflecting the uncertainty of
estimating a large task or a large story
it's it's literally it's impossible so
let's uh increase the increments as we
go up those uh those levels from large
to extra large and beyond
that's a a really really nice system and
has worked well for us
so we've got some effort points in we're
basically saying all of our team agree
that deploying to aws lambda is a really
hard task for us giving our background
on our skills and is much harder than
building the fast api app it's much
harder than uh throwing in dvc into the
system it's much harder than just uh the
the 20 character change of switching our
model out and re-running our test suite
so that's our effort points and if your
teams don't agree
the planning meeting is where you say
okay why do you think that's a one and
you think that's a five maybe there's
something we missed there maybe there's
some uncertainty maybe there's uh things
we didn't anticipate so let's have that
conversation we get better at planning
collaboratively
so your developers or your data science
your team is estimating effort the
stakeholders which is sometimes just the
team manager estimates value and so the
value doesn't always equal the effort
something's really easy to do and just
provide insane amounts of value some
things are really hard to do and they're
not that valuable so
again we throw in some value points
along the same system
then we can just calculate a value per
effort score sort by that score identify
some dependencies or tasks that have to
happen in a certain order and then just
do a rank ordering and this is great
because now for the rest of the sprint
my team can just start taking tasks from
the top knowing that they're working on
the most valuable work given the effort
and the tasks near the bottom they're
more like the nice to haves uh there's
more effort the less value
so self-organizing teams that requires
much less management through that sprint
cycle now if you're first implementing
this for the first time sprint number
one don't worry about this like just
make up the numbers and see what happens
uh review at the end calculate the total
effort points completed and then
calculate what we call a velocity score
which is how many effort points did you
complete in your sprint cycle or per day
and that gives you your rough estimate
as to how many effort points do we even
put on the board for the next sprint and
you're going to get better once you
start tracking your velocity you're
going to get better at tracking more
tasks and also there's a really curious
effect your velocity is going to go up
over time so this is uh velocity and
value delivered by my operations team um
over over the last few months and what's
happened here is we've got better at
prioritizing more high impact work
better roi work is going to be sprint
and the lower uh value work is uh maybe
being uh delayed until later or even
just we're realizing it's not as high
value as everything else we're doing at
the moment so an amazing thing starts to
happen now this will tell the first time
is you just get really good at
consistently delivering high value work
uh that
this is something you will grow to
become accustomed to what is your
velocity
uh for a team of two people maybe six
years at points in two weeks
do you take into account half status law
it always takes longer than you expect
even you're into taking into account how
status law top tip okay so segueing into
some more practical tips and tricks to
learn from the last 12 months of me
trying this out as a total newcomer so
uh stories can roll over into the next
print you have finished something just
roll over don't try and get your team to
finish everything in time
uh communicate upwards really carefully
send people this video
and just understand that things change
bugs happen data science is hard it's
literally research and development
allow for that uncertainty uh don't make
your teams burn out trying to just hit
their sprint deadlines that's crazy uh
discuss why your teams underestimated
these things revise the effort points
going into the next sprint learn from
that become better at forecasting and it
all ends up sort of in the wash over
several sprints you're going to claim
the points in the next print it doesn't
matter
uh daily stand up make it about the
items not the people and also lots of
people do sound ups like first thing in
the morning consider other times have a
conversation with your team is 9 a.m
really the best time for your team maybe
they just want to come into work and
just crack on with the thing that they
were halfway through when they finished
yesterday uh so we do a midday stand up
which we learned from another london
startup works really well for us
okay use spikes if you're not sure about
how long something's going to take don't
spend forever trying to estimate it use
a fixed time box window say
okay we don't know how to deploy onto a
google cloud function we've never done
that before we don't know how to
estimate how long that will take so what
we're going to do is a three hour spike
this one person is gonna go and just
spend three hours researching it
effectively that's enough time we think
into how long it's gonna take to know
how long it will take to then go ahead
and do that or to break it down into the
right stories so if you can't estimate
things uh just build the uncertainty and
that's a three-hour spike a three-point
story in your board
never skip retro
it's too valuable it's your optimization
process
and your teams
will not forgive you if you skip this
continuously over and over again it
doesn't matter how important the
deadlines are uh this is an investment
in your team's future productivity
i think it's a really nice idea to align
your epics with quarters as in have a
definition of done on your epics if you
use akrs it works really well at okrs it
forces you to actually look at the big
headline stories that you're looking at
and say do we actually still want to do
this is this still valuable for business
or have we now just spent three months
trying to build a machine learning model
for one-shot learning and it turns out
this is really hard and it's like a
we need a whole research team of uh phds
and postdocs to achieve this and maybe
we bit off more than we can chew so
conscious story roll over it also is an
opportunity to re-prioritize and
readdress your technical debt that may
have gained in the quarter
evolve your system through retros
let your team innovate they will
understand how to be more productive for
themselves and finally don't try to
replicate someone else's agile type not
you know
make it your own uh your company's
culture is unique your team's culture is
unique so just let things evolve and
learn what works for you
okay so some tools of the trade this is
what we've used this is what worked well
for us if you're just wondering where to
start we use gitlab predominantly for
our own internal work but we use jira
github projects um for client work we've
done some zenhub work and zenhub is a
like a github
uh chrome plugin that sort of does stuff
on github and then they've got their own
service so it's a really nice agile
project management tool for github
and i've dabbled with that and i think
that actually looks really nice so
it's a hardcore between gitlab and
zenhub because zenhub has all the effort
points and value points built into it as
well as things like planning poker
spreadsheets we use a lot of because we
can just automate the connections of
data between like github apis into
spreadsheets and then
this works really well for stuff at
gitlab or whatever tool we're using for
the client doesn't work so well we can
just throw the data in capture the
effort points of the value points from
the client sort by our our value scoring
and off we go
also means we can do all the analytics
on top we actually use monday for our
agile operations we use range is really
honest well discovered this last quarter
for async stand-ups meeting automation
okr tracking and then metro retro is my
favorite tool for retrospectives don't
just do retros with like a notebook or
meeting notes or whatever use a proper a
retro tool like miro or metro retro it's
fun confetti at the end is great
okay so myth number five agile is for
software teams it's absolutely not um
marketing agile uh
is is uh increasingly popular agile ups
is also increasingly popular here is a
little insight in just how we do agile
within our own startup operations and it
works really well uh our team is really
enjoying it we're moving faster we're
delivering more we've got the kanban
board there if you're gone ops team and
you want to replicate our little board
we can just talk to us and and uh we'll
give that away for you
okay so last few minutes uh advice for
leaders so if you are running a team
i'm speaking to you now and if you are a
member of team uh again send this video
to your to your senior leaders if you
like the idea of agile and uh
this is my advice so first of all agile
is for startups total myth okay john
deere huge tractor farming manufacturer
implemented agile years ago they saw 75
reduction in their project cycle times
developing machines from
uh eight months instead of sort of two
three years
uh their teams were happier much happier
uh the velocity how much work you're
doing per sprint increased 2x 3x 5x 9x
uh amazing improvement and just
productivity and it's not just concierge
quality they actually were able to prove
that quality also measurably improved so
it's really fantastic for your team
leaders um article on harvard business
review which i've linked to here called
embracing agile with loads more of these
case studies
also agile is the best practice delivery
standard for uk government projects uh
one of my other favorite resources is
the gov dot uk uh service delivery
manual on agile delivery step by step
101 to agile
so here's my advice for your leaders
lead with questions not with orders okay
don't tell your teams how you want
things done let them figure out tell
them what you'd like to do
if it's good enough for george patton
it's good enough for me uh guide them
with the questions understand how could
we test these things how are we going to
measure this
and through doing so you will grow your
technical leads and becoming better
general managers
don't switch to agile too quickly 63 of
the organizations that failed in agile
is most often because of clashes between
business culture and agile philosophy so
don't switch your entire companies out
on one go do it in small batches uh send
everyone the video see who's interested
start there iterate learn tweak adapt
your process build success stories in
terms of inside your company and uh just
iterate be lean use agile to do agile so
final tips and tricks uh next steps
recommended reading
made tech have great written this great
book it's free online downloadable ebook
uh building high performance agile teams
i've learnt so much from that book
of just how to get things done
then the phoenix project i just think
it's really fun it's a novel it's kind
of funny kind of painful because it's so
close to home
and
if you get the book version it includes
the devops handbook in the back which is
then like a really like step-by-step
checklist and the agile service delivery
manual as i as i mentioned
finally uh i'll leave this load up a
moment longer uh bit dot these four pi
data hyphen
agile and you can see just a little
table of contents this is uh just uh
opened up our own playbook because this
is not our call competency we do
analytics and data and machine learning
and stuff uh but we've learned all of
this and i'm quite happy to try and
share it so what you get here is sort of
step-by-step agendas notes about how to
do this well uh we're continually adding
to this we have just a very agile lean
process about how we run our own
internal operations and then all of the
tricks and the links and i'll put this
video once it's available publicly i'll
put this video link there as well
so thank you very much uh you can
find our our details here feel free to
reach out to us if you want to talk to
me about anything i've talked about
today and otherwise have a great
surprise to global i will be in the
gather afterwards to take questions hand
in the slacks
thank you very much for your uh for your
nice talk i'm sure that all of the
attendees uh enjoyed and also learned
many things
excellent i am screenshotting all of
these questions and i'll answer them in
the slack somewhere awesome awesome
thank you very much john